The Joe Rogan Experience I don't know
about your 20s I don't know what you did
in your 20s but my 20s have been like
this crazy roller coaster
they've just like it hasn't stopped and
I'm like holy [__] this is what they
meant by the 20s or yeah psychotic I
mean you're just over being 10. yeah 10
17 years ago and you think you know
everything man when you're 22 and 23
it's so scary of course decisions and
[__] you make it's crazy you got into
you got into making music well I say you
were successful making music while you
were still in the military right yes how
old were you 22 when I started wow I
started putting videos on Twitter and it
was psychotic it was crazy because I did
it for like
I get all these messages all the time
from people who are like hey man I was
around when you release heading south
I've been here from the beginning and
I'm like wow really the very beginning
you know and um
I started putting videos on Twitter back
in like 2017 and then I just kept doing
it and doing it doing it because I was
in the Navy I had a lot of [__] going on
I had like
I didn't believe in therapy because
that's crazy in the Navy you know and uh
I started just making music and I
started posting them on Twitter and
people I'd get like five or six likes
and I didn't care it was nice it was
nice to go home
it was nice to go home and feel the way
I did and right and put music on Twitter
I don't know it was kind of my
validation in the world of I can write a
song at least right and then man one I
was I was training in Florida and one
day I put like four or five videos up
and they just went like crazy viral and
I was like
cool neat and then my life just kept
going up and up and up and I was like at
that time did you have any what were
your your aspirations about recording no
I didn't even know what it was that's
why my beginning records are shitty you
never they're not shitty but
see when I recorded this when I recorded
this I was about to like
go inside I was like whatever I'll just
throw this on the internet and it was
like another iPhone and it was like the
number one voted Reddit video in the
entire like world I think I don't know
but I was like getting calls from people
I'm like what the hell is going on
everyone at work like you're going viral
I was like what and we're like literally
like learning how to load missiles and
[__] I'm like cool sick man and uh
it's been crazy and I never I never in
my life envisioned being a musician ever
really period no I thought I was getting
my old man was in the Navy for 25 years
he was a master chief my mom was in the
Navy my grandpa was in the Navy
both yeah just that that like whatever
and I was like I'm gonna be in the Navy
till the day I die probably until I
retire at least
and that was it that was going to be my
life and I was thinking about it
yesterday how crazy
my reality is now like coming back to
Oklahoma and being around people and
people like coming to get me in diners I
mean like take a picture of me I'm like
what is going on man there's like 700
people hating me online I'm like bro I
didn't [__] mean to do this
I don't I'm sorry it's crazy wow it just
kept going it's crazy it's absolutely
crazy
yeah it is a crazy story right it is
yeah and being in the Navy for like nine
years beforehand is even crazy because
no one ever talks about that I'm like
bro I busted my ass man I was I was like
in Africa and [__] uh Bahrain and
stuff and I was like what'd you do in
Africa and Bahrain
I was a this is a this is a crazy story
in itself but
I won't tell the whole thing uh tell the
whole thing
[__]
okay so Mark open a second Bud Light and
let's go like I said about my dad he was
in the Navy for like 25 years so I was
uh hey man look at you hey man uh dork
bro
I've always loved dressed Blues though
that is sick uh you ever heard that song
dress blues by Isabel no you gotta it's
beautiful it's beautiful but um
my dad was in the Navy for like 25 years
and my mom was in the Navy like I said
earlier my grandpa was in the Navy
and so growing up when I was like 14
years old I was like man I'm gonna be in
the Navy that's all I want to do I want
to like die for this country man it's
best country in the world I want to be
in it I want to experience that whole
like Empire State Building thing where
yeah you're devoted to something yeah
and so I turned 17 and my dad was a
recruiter in Oklahoma and I was like
okay cool so he like helped me get
recruited and I was supposed to go in
the Navy as a diver
but [__] fell through my dad was like
it'll be fine you'll get to boot camp
and they'll ask you if you want to be a
diver and then you could just say yes
and it'll be fine
so okay sick it's like get on a [__]
bus and I'm like let's do this and I was
nervous I was scared man I was terrified
because as like a kid you don't really
know what to expect in the military
and um
I like end up at boot camp which is
crazy and I was terrified and then I
realized it was all just
kind of routine and stuff like that and
I got out of boot camp
actually no that's not the whole story I
was trying to be a diver and and uh one
day they were like hey you're gonna get
to
you're going to get to reclass what
you're doing
and they gave me like
two options
and it was like be it Master at Arms
which is like a cop in the military or
be a Aviation ordinance man which is
like the dudes who like load the bombs
and things on planes and I was pissed at
my dad
I was like what the hell man I thought
you said I was gonna get to be a diver
I called him I'm like dude you suck man
and so my buddies were all AOS which in
the Navy they're all [__] made fun of
because they're all like big old dumb
idiots
and then I became an AO and I went to a
school to be an AO and it was amazing
man I met some of those beautiful people
I've ever met I've learned more than
I've ever learned
but while I got stationed in Nebraska
and
and I hate I hate this I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna oversell this because I don't
want to sound tough but I trained to be
a seal for like two years with this guy
named Senior Chief Lundqvist out of
Omaha Nebraska
and I trained really really hard I took
a bunch of these psts and I would call
my mom like every day she would ask me
how far I ran how far I swam how how
many like how much I lifted and [__]
and then I don't take it lightly either
I never I'm not tough it never happened
but I wanted to go to buds really bad
because like I said I wanted to do
something that was greater than myself
and then the day the day my package came
back for the seal the buds thing my mama
died and I was like well [__] man this
sucks this is crazy and all the while I
was in AO and I hated I hated it I was
like oh [__] now I gotta be an ordinance
man
and um
when she passed away I was like man I
don't want to do that I don't want to I
don't really want to pursue that so I
bitched out for sure and I wish I
wouldn't have sometimes but like life is
crazy my chief my chief who's like high
ranking he looked at me and I was like
man you want to go out there and die or
something why do you want to do this so
bad and I was like I guess you're right
and
it's one of those stories in my life
where I kind of I look back and I'm like
man if things would have been different
what would have happened but uh she
passed away and then I moved to
Washington to be an ordinance man and as
soon as I [__] landed in Washington
they sent me
they sent me to the desert this Bahraini
desert to like learn how to like build
missiles and load missiles
crazy and it was sick man it was
beautiful so I I was you had to build
missiles as in like load them or as in
like disassemble and reassemble oh and
this is this is different from EOD
there's explosive ordinance disposal and
then there's EOS which AOS are kind of
just like the the little tiny baby
cousin of not even they're not even
connected EOD there's some badass guys
AOS are just the dude to build load arm
and the arm the bombs that are on the
planes that are taken off just but just
build bombs no big deal yeah it's cool
man it's neat and uh but [__]
it's crazy so I was in the desert man I
was [__] like 19 years old like oh
[__] okay I'm here
and uh I was like I was a sand sailor
for sure I never I never like uh was on
a ship
and so that was my first deployment I
fell in love with it I wanted to do it
like always I was like this is amazing I
had this really great Gunner Gunner's
like your your officer above you
and he just inspired me so much to be
the best that I could be like every day
so I go into work and dude I was a
[__] kiss ass like in the Navy
everyone hated me so I was like let's do
it let's go to war man let's go and
we're just doing Simple [__] like eating
dinner you know and uh
but I fell in love with it and I wanted
to do it forever and so
we would like launch planes out and like
do the keys and [__] to arm the missiles
that took off and things like that
and uh I forgot what your damn question
was I'm so sorry like at the very
beginning
I don't remember what the exact question
was either oh yeah just being in the
Navy in general and uh what was what
were you talking about we were talking
about something in specific specific
story exactly and I said I didn't want
to tell the whole story and then I
thought God damn it oh I was just saying
that I was in for like nine I was in for
like nine years and no one ever talks
about that [__] now and I was like but
and then I went to Djibouti Africa which
was crazy that's right I asked you about
Africa and I want to ask you about about
Bahrain yeah that's that's what started
it yeah and then uh I was in Africa for
like did I've been in Africa like a year
of my life I was deployed there twice
and it's like I loved every second of it
because I'd wake up at 5am 5 a.m every
morning and like go eat breakfast go
like load your plane
go eat lunch [__] how what part of
Africa were you in Djibouti and where's
that the horn it's like right on the
edge either top of
I'm gonna sound like an idiot was there
a lot of wildlife no we were stuck on
the base oh the whole time you can't
even go off the base it's crazy Camp
Luminaire yeah and it's but it's cool
though because there's like eight gems
man and like food that's all you do and
you're as happy as you're as happy as
[__] because it's so simple that is wild
and you go to breakfast workout go do
your job work out
that's what it looks like there no way
yeah a little shittier where we were man
it's cool
and so you're just on the base and
that's it yeah and then every every
morning like whether there's like
cluster bombs or whatever you'd like go
you'd go
assemble them or load them and [__] and
it was it was really crazy
wow yeah and then
like I said one day I just like ended up
like it was overnight one day I just
went to [__] Jacksonville Florida and
was playing my guitar on Twitter and it
like blew up and then my chief was like
hey man it's crazy you gotta [__]
this is a this is a conflict of interest
man because I'm famous yeah I was like
I think they were scared that I would
show up to work and just be like [__]
you guys man I don't need this you know
it never happened I would never do that
because I was so devoted to being in the
Navy but they thought you they were
losing all power over exactly which is
crazy to think about man and I had this
[__]
my uh my Gunner one day comes up to me
and he's like hey man this is getting
crazy you gotta get out of the Navy
I'm like okay whatever uh do I have to
and he's like yeah
and I was like I'd rather not and he's
like okay too bad and then he was like
okay you'll be out of the Navy next week
and I'm like
that's crazy all right been doing this
for eight years now
and then it took eight months
to process me out of the Navy
and it was crazy because every day I
would go into work and think like oh
this is my last day in the Navy cool for
eight months this is my last day you
gotta work as hard as you possibly can
man Make It Count Make It Count make it
count and every day I'd go in and just
bust my ass and then dude find like six
months in I'm like I'm in the [__]
Navy forever man sounds good Jesus
Christ why is that
is that just standard for paperwork it's
never happened it's never like I I think
don't quote me but like Elvis Presley
was the last guy who got like honorably
discharged out to my music
and I'm not I'm not like being arrogant
in that either I think that's true and
it just never happens like that there's
been a lot of stuff with um like NFL
players who are like at the Academy the
Naval Academy who like are really good
at football and getting drafted to the
NFL they have to like get transferred
out and stuff like that but it's never
happened like some Joe [__] the rag man
AO like me and that's when I knew it
that wouldn't do when my Gunner called
me that day and he's like pack your bags
I was like holy oh this is that serious
I called my dad I thought he was going
to be disappointed because
he was a Master Chief and stuff and I
was supposed to be a master chief my dad
had like a bottle of whiskey when I was
a kid that said Mass Chief Brian on it
for me when I made Master Chief wow I
thought when I called my dad he'd be
disappointed but he was like Hey man
come home do it
and I thought it would flop I thought I
thought it'd be nothing in the year you
were already successful online yeah
exactly exactly
but I still I still I never like played
a show
or anything
and then we went like I gotta remember
your first one oh yeah what was it it
was uh the pageant in St Louis Missouri
how many people there wasn't a very
first one this is unfair to say like my
best friends in Washington when I was in
the Navy I used to play at this place
called uh
I used to play like shitty acoustic sets
at this place called um
off the hook more like all the sailors
went like on the weekends and [__] they
had like
and my best friends Austin and Kramer
they used to come to the bar and watch
me these two [__] dudes looking at me
play and every time I'd finished a song
they'd clap for me man because they're
they're real friends you know
and that was like the very first show I
ever played but the pageant in St Louis
I got out of the Navy and
um
here's what's weird for me because
musicians have a I'm talking way too
much I apologize no you're not at all
musicians have
usually a pipeline which drives me crazy
I don't know why but they have a
pipeline of like
oh man I played small Wars and then I
played
bigger small bars and then I played the
bigger bigger small bars then I go into
medium venues and then I went to
bigger medium venue and they have this
like thing where they they're proud of
it of course which I would be too that's
a journey but when I got out of the Navy
I was already like
there so I like hopped on a [__] tour
bus like hey you're going to the pageant
in St Louis play WoW how many people is
that I think 2 000 2500 wow which was
crazy for me because I never played Asia
and people blame me a lot for this like
they they get mad at me and I'm like bro
I didn't [__] do this I didn't mean
for this to happen and why are they mad
at you exactly I agree and it freaks me
out too and I just like I wish I could
just uh I wish I could just like talk to
people and be like hey man